un objeto no identificado adicional en
la saga Washington derribó el domingo
uno de forma octagonal sobre el lagoron
llevando a cuatro el número de aparatos
aéreos derivados por Estados Unidos y
Canadá en urus Aunque el primero fue
reconocido como un globo de vigilancia
chino por las autoridades
estadounidenses estas no han podido
confirmar la naturaleza de los otros
tres objetos pero varios funcionarios
dijeron que no coincidían con la flota
de globos de vigilancia aérea chinos he
estado en contacto con el departamento
de defensa con respecto a las
operaciones en la región de los grandes
lagos hoy el ejército estadounidense ha
derribado otro objeto sobre el lago
Hurón agradezco la acción decisiva de
nuestros pilotos de combate el pueblo
estadounidense merece muchas más
respuestas de las que tenemos la falta
de información oficial al respecto llevo
mucha gente a hacer especulaciones en
las redes sociales e incluso la
administración biden tuvo que asegurar
que no existen pruebas de que se trate
una actividad extraterrestre pero
tampoco lo descartó una mayor
observación del espacio aéreo tras la
incursión china explica para el
pentágono el descubrimiento de estos
nuevos objetos
tras el derivo del globo de China el
sábado pasado hemos estado haciendo un
escrutinio más detallado de nuestro
espacio aéreo y Eso incluye mejorar
nuestro radar lo que explica el aumento
en la detección de objetos en la última
semana según el representante del
Congreso estadounidense las sesiones
informativas de los últimos años han
dejado Claro que hay mucha basura en el
cielo